let's go to the phones 617 830 4750 is
the number for the first caller today
the day of Donald Trump's inauguration
I'm going to go to an area code that
reminds me of the origins of the david
pakman show caller in the 413 area code
in western mass what's your name where
are you calling from and what's on your
mind all right David yes this is Jake
this is jamie how are you good how are
you I love good listen I love your show
but listen I have a question for ya will
you call enjoy first ragazzo were you
calling hey i'm calling from springfield
mass okay thank you got it but well this
is a little driving me crazy yep
everything that this man has done
everything that he has showed to us okay
at this point okay why are we giving
this man a free pass okay well who's
leaving an ugly fast I mean wenis
independent progressive media is not
giving the guy a free pass it's the
people who voted for him who are giving
him the free pass right yeah but this is
what I'm saying it's like anybody else
that did any of the things that he's
doing as a nominee young president legs
yeah anybody else we would have kicked
them out of the house I think it goes to
this idea that epsilon and whatever
attacks are levied against them it just
kind of brushes off of them yeah he says
that that's what happens and that's what
happens right like he it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy he said I could
shoot people on Fifth Avenue and nothing
would happen and indeed he's done the
political equivalent of doing that
making fun of disabled people women
doesn't sexual assault accusations yeah
and it all falls office anybody anybody
else's that would even think about
making fun of that a handicapped or
disabled person yeah they will do they
will grab him by his cool tails and kick
them out right but so it hasn't happened
or so then now what what do we do now
exactly and it's like not releasing its
taxes we all thought everyone else
thought you know what as a person
running for president you have to show
your tactics right okay it even
it's not that important but the whole
thing is like he's he's not he's not
going up reduces taxes and everybody's
safe long as I'm president it I'm like
okay so it is against the law is there a
rule that he's breaking it's either a
temporary that's the thing it's been
tradition but he's not going to do it
and it would be hugely damaging to him
clearly if he did and this is why today
marks the beginning of an uphill battle
of four years and I think you've
explained the frustration I hear in your
voice Jamie is exactly why we need to be
active for the next four years I've got
to move on I really do appreciate the
call always great to hear from people in
the 413 area code